i don't want to move too far ahead
without touching on
big love because that seemed like
it could have been a very big moment for
you specifically when you decided to
leave the show
and i am curious what was driving the
interest at that point in your career to
put the focus on film in particular
i had gotten mamma mia and i shot mamma
mia
with the same people that produced big
love
and playtone and uh i wasn't
they were there was just not enough work
to make it make sense it was the story
wasn't about me and that's fine that was
always an
ensemble and and was mostly surrounded
the wives you know those are the meaty
parts not to say that i didn't have some
fantastic writing
and some fantastic scenes and storylines
i mean
big love is really
important to me and uh important for my
career
but by the end it was just like i can't
hold babies anymore i i mean there's
just like i have to
i have to capitalize on this moment i
remember when i got mamma mia when i
found out i had
gotten it we i was back on set and
this is before we shouted of course and
and bill paxton comes around the corner
of the production office
and like puts his arms out he's like you
did it and he ran into his arm and he
picked me up and spun me around and it
was like he was very much like a father
to me
um and it was so wonderful because i had
all the support of them too so much
support from my big willow family
and of course you know those those run
deep those ties
run really deep so that was definitely
it was time to go